ليس صالح العاروري اول من تغتال اسرائيل
من قاده حركه حماس وقد لا يكون الاخير لا
سما في ظل بلوغ الصراع التاريخي بين
الجانبين ذروه غير مسبوقه من ذروات حرب
الاباده والتدمير والتهجير التي من فك
الشعب الفلسطيني يتعرض لها بمتفجرات
اسرائيل وطائراتها منذ انشئت كيانا سياسيا
على ارض وطنه قبل نحو ثمانيه عقود طبعا
هذا الاحتلال الصهيوني الاجرامي من اليوم
الاول الذي حل فيه في فلسطين قام على اساس
اقتلاع شعبنا وتهجيره كان العاروري
المولود في بلده عاره قرب رام الله عام
66 يشغل حتى لحظه اغتياله منصب نائب رئيس
المكتب السياسي لحركه حماس فضلا عن وصفه
ايضا بانه احد مؤسسي جناحها العسكري كتائب
الشهيد عز الدين القسام في الضفه الغربيه
مطلع تسعينيات القرن الماضي وتلك حقبه
اعتقلته سلطات الاحتلال خلالها مرات عده
ليرز في السجون الاسرائيليه اكثر من 15
سنه قبل نفيه قصرا الى خارج فلسطين عام
2010 بهذا المعنى انضم الرجل الى قافله من
قاده حماس الشهداء يتصدرها مؤسس الحرب
الشيخ احمد ياسين وتضم خليفته في زعامتها
الدكتور عبد العزيز الرنتيسي واخرين كثر
ابرزهم صلاح شحاده واسماعيل ابو شنب
وابراهيم المقادمه وسعيد صيام واحمد
الجعبري هو ايضا انضم الى ما يزيد على 22
الف فلسطيني قتلتهم اسرائيل او ابادتهم في
قطاع غزه منذ السابع من تشرين اول اكتوبر
الماضي اضافه فه الى عشرات الوف اخرين ما
فتئت تقتلهم بلا توقف ولا رحمه ولا اعتبار
للقوانين الدوليه والقيم الانسانيه على
مدى سنوات الاحتلال كل يوم في شهداء ونحنا
في حركه حماس جزء من هذا الشعب ولذلك
نستشهد مثل شعبنا بستشهد ما احنا جزء منه
لكن عمليه الاغتيال الجديده تتميز عن كل
سابقاتها بما قد يجعل منها صاعقه تفجير او
وصفه لتوسيع نطاق الحرب الاسرائيليه
المستمره على غزه منذ نحو ثلاثه شهور
والمقصود بذلك مكان التنفيذ الذي غامرت
اسرائيل
باستباحة ده منظمات فلسطينيه سواها لن
يلتفت الكثيرون هنا الى ما قد يوصفوا
بارهاب الدوله المتمثل اساسا في ان ترسل
دوله طائراتها لتقتل اشخاصا في دوله اخرى
ذات سياده تلك فعله ارتكبت اسرائيل ما
يشبهها مرات ومرات لعل اشهرها اغتيال
القائد العسكري لحركه فتح خليل الوزير ابو
جهاد في تونس عام
88 من القرن الماضي اضافه الى ملاحقتها
وقتلها قاده فلسطينيين اخرين في بلدان
عربيه واوربيه كثيره بيد ان المكان في هذه
المره له حيثيه اخرى سوى السياده وما
يرتبط بها من قوانين دوليه هنا ضاحيه
بيروت الجنوبيه معقل حزب الله الذي سبق له
ان حذر اسرائيل من تجاوز خط احمر كهذا لا
جواب حاسما حتى الان بالطبع على السؤال عن
التوقعات في هذا الشان وان كانت التحليلات
الاوليه تولد من الحدث اسئله اخرى شديده
الحساسيه هل اقدمت حكومه الحرب في اسرائيل
على اغتيال العاروري لان رئيسها بنيامين
نتنياهو يتوخى اشعال المنطقه كي يواصل
الفرار من محاكمته باتهامات الفساد
والتقصير ام انها ما كانت لترتكب ما
ارتكبت لولا اطمئنانها الى قدره حلفائها
وفي مقدمتهم الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
على ضبط ردود الفعل بما يحول دون اي تفجير
جدي خارج حدود
غزه على اي حال وبصرف النظر عن الابعاد
والتفاعلات التي لن يطول الانتظار
لاكتشافها فان المكشوف الذي لا جدال فيه
هو انجراف اسرائيل نحو مزيد من التطرف
واستمرار ولوغه في الدم الفلسطيني دون ما
راد